I'm joined today by Alex Mohajir who is
the co-founder of Bros for America a
progressive advocacy organization and a
political writer and commentator for the
Huffington Post you will soon remember
when we mentioned an article by Alex
just a few weeks ago Alex was on Fox
News last night with Chakra Carlson it
escalated very very quickly talking
about an article that Alex wrote which
explains if indeed Donald Trump's
election was precipitated influenced by
Russia that there would be instructional
data from a prior court case that could
tell us how Donald Trump might be might
be removed as president and of course
that argument was drastically misstated
yesterday by Tucker Carlson Alex before
we get to the questions let's just
review a little bit of that appearance
from last night and your judge or a
panel of judges removing him would be
more democratic than the election result
it seems like the opposite is found no
if it is found that there was wrongdoing
such as collusion with the with the
Russian government to hack our elections
or that he knew was bogus people on the
name of partisanship well since we each
other's arguments it's at your trial
instead of listen no no okay so Alex
Tucker Carlson laughs I disparaged you
personally said it's all crazy but the
question is not whether Trump is a
legitimate president or not maybe we'll
know that for sure at some point the
question is if it were determined that
he were not what legal mechanism might
exist to remove him well first of all
let me say I am saying you know
in my opinion he's an illegitimate
president so I understand I I knew going
into Fox News last night that he was
going to attack me on that I knew it I I
anticipated that what I didn't
anticipate was that he was going to skew
the argument and make it about something
so irrelevant and so just sort of
tangential to the to the entire case
that it it basically it was just meant
to make me look sort of nuts and and try
to get me with a gotcha moment but
didn't address the argument at all and
the shame about that is that most of the
reaction that's come from people that
are Fox News viewers which has been
insane has basically taken that bit of
it as being the argument which it's not
at all so that's unfortunate so let's
let's begin let's have a conversation
starting for the beginning for the right
now let's put aside that you happen to
be of the opinion that Trump is not a
legitimate president and let's let's
have the conversation about what you
presented in your Huffington Post piece
which has now gone very very viral what
would be the mechanism that could be
used to remove Donald Trump from the
White House okay so first of all if if
something like this were to happen it
would need to happen because a court is
deciding on a controversy that's been
brought before them right judges don't
just issue decrees or remove somebody
from office and I don't know if that is
made clear in my piece because I assume
that people assume that and it seems
like the feedback from people who don't
understand the system it seems to
suggest that they don't realize that I'm
that that's innate in the argument so
you know it would need to happen through
a court case and as I'm aware there are
a couple that are before different
district courts right now that we just
haven't heard about in the press but I
know there's one in the first district
and one in the third District supposedly
there's a case going up before Justice
Ginsburg today still we'll see I mean
it's
we'll see how it goes but if those
controversies come before the court what
I'm saying is there is federal case law
on point that says that the judge that
courts have broad discretionary power in
in remedying interferences with our free
and fair elections and tell us about
what that where that instruction comes
from which you cite in the article of
course yeah well in the article I do
cite to mark Mark's V Stinson this is
Bruce Wayne by the way this is Alex's
Dunn people who are listening to the
podcast Alex's dog is getting very
agitated by the talk of legal
proceedings he hates it marks V Stinson
it's a case from 1994 out of the out of
Pennsylvania and it's a federal court
case and the first and only that I could
find that saw a judge basically take the
sitting state senator out of
Pennsylvania at the time and replace him
with his opponent from the election the
previous November's election and it's
because there was a showing of voter
fraud that came up in that in that case
and and that judge his authority to
replace the candidate was never called
into question there were up there were
procedural you know mishaps that
occurred along the way but that was that
was basically upheld as being the
takeaway from that case is that judges
especially federal district courts have
broad discretionary power in in issuing
equity decrees so that you can make sure
that we have free and fair elections
that is an a sentiment that's never come
up before the Supreme Court in terms of
a presidential election being overturned
but there is even case law that I
mentioned in my piece as well it's
Donahue the Donahue case which didn't
actually hear the issue but did I give a
a holding that said that that at the
presidential level there would be
authority to hold annual
election for instance so I think look
where it starts to get a little complex
is here we're talking about can we prove
a negative
in a sense which would be even if you
could show that there was an attempt
made by Russia to influence the outcome
of the election and I believe at this
point it is unquestionable that that
attempt was made and even if you could
argue that in a sense some influence
took place it's very hard to say what
was the total impact of that influence
and would someone else really have one
and it's I don't know how you
demonstrate that right so this is where
I think it's also very interesting is at
least in the case law that I read you
wouldn't need to show that that the
empty outcome would have been changed
for certain all you have to show is that
it could have been changed or it could
have been impacted by the wrongdoing and
then you have to show the wrongdoing and
show that it cast doubt on the
electorate as to the will of the as to
the will of the electorate so I I posed
the question in the article does James
commis letter to Congress pose a
question as to whether or not the will
of the electorate is reflected in the
outcome you know and then I point to
different facts about the election that
that suggests that yes because this is a
point that's not being driven home by
anyone whether it's mainstream or
conservative media the election was lost
in the electoral college with seventy
nine thousand votes in Michigan
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin seventy nine
thousand and that's uh that's pretty
that's that's a stark comparison when
you look at the total number of votes
being around one hundred and thirty six
million that's saying that a less than
1/10 of a hundredth of a percentage
points you know it fell on that so did
James Comey use letter to Congress
effect seventy nine thousand votes
especially when I show evidence in my
piece that there reflect fifty million
media mentions negative media mentions
in the the final we
of the campaign about Hillary Clinton's
emails and James Comey used letter to
Congress you know that I think the third
most talked about negative media
controversy was I don't have it right in
front of me but I think it was the ha
Access Hollywood tapes and that got 5
million negative media mentions so when
you look at that 50 million versus 5 is
it reasonable to say that that could
have affected 79 thousand votes could it
have that's what marks me Stinson is
saying is the standard could it have if
so then the federal district court and
it's you know broad discretionary power
has the authority to say well the will
of the electorate is not reflected let's
have a new election let's say you're
right let's read let's say you're right
let's say you're completely correcting
in your reading of that case from a
pragmatic perspective which judge is
going to be the one that puts their name
on on making that call oh I to be sure I
don't have any illusions about thinking
that this is something that's plausible
and I was interviewed by PolitiFact
about this and I said you know the
likelihood that this happens is very
slim does it mean that it can't happen
or that it's impossible no and I think
that we have a one of the things I talk
about in my piece is Americans and our
and our culture of being quick to find
we are sort of urged to seek closure
more than we are to seek answers right
we're not supposed to mourn too long or
too hard or too loudly because that goes
against the script and just because it's
never been done before doesn't mean that
it shouldn't be mentioned as possible
for posterity sake and for you know the
states the sake of justice for those of
us who believe that the election is you
know the the outcome of the election is
not reflective of the will of the
electorate make sure to check out Alex's
piece in Huffington Post if you can
stomach the toxicity check out his
interview from last night with Tucker
Carlson on fox news as well we've been
speaking with Alex Mojave
Alex thanks so much for talking to us
about this thank you guys thank you